How do you become the highest grossing
director of all time? Easy — don't go
to film school. These iconic directors didn't
need formal training to make movie masterpieces.
If it wasn't for Peter Jackson, our vision of
Middle-earth would look a whole lot different
today. Jackson's "Lord of the Rings"
adaptations won seventeen Academy Awards
across three movies thanks to their grand scale,
groundbreaking special effects, and epic scores.
Jackson knew from a young age
that he wanted to be a filmmaker,
but he wasn't interested in attending school
outside New Zealand to make that happen. The
nation's film industry wasn't substantial in
the 1980s, so he had to do things himself.
"I never went to film school, so I don't even
know what film schools do, to tell you the truth."
After dropping out of high school at
the age of 16, Jackson worked hard
to earn enough money to purchase his
own 16mm camera. Jackson's first film,
"Bad Taste," was shot on that very camera, and
premiered at the Cannes Film Festival in 1987.
Jackson's career was launched with a film
that sits snugly in the splatter-horror genre,
and he used his success to create more
of the same with 1993's "Dead Alive."
He gained international attention with
1994's "Heavenly Creatures," which opened
the door for his first Hollywood film, "The
Frighteners." Of course, it wasn't until
"The Lord of the Rings" that the director
found himself thrust into the stratosphere.
James Cameron is one of the world's most
successful directors — but unlike many
of his peers, he doesn't have the
most consistent output. Instead,
he spends years working on his projects,
often developing new technology to bring his
imagined worlds to life. He's made several
of the highest grossing films ever made,
and there's a simple reason for that: he's a
brilliant storyteller who cares about the details.
Cameron studied physics at a community college,
but transitioned to English before dropping out.
He then worked as a truck driver while pursuing
his interest in film technology. After seeing
"Star Wars" in 1977, Cameron knew for sure
that he wanted to pursue a film career.
Cameron's big break came when he sold the
rights to "The Terminator" for just $1. He
did this on one condition, though: he had
to be allowed to direct the movie himself.
Years later, Rick Schultz asked Cameron
in an interview if film school was a good
place for aspiring creators to hone
their skills. The director replied —
"When I started out, I was working
as a truck driver. Didn't have much
spare cash. Certainly couldn't
afford film school. But all you
have to do is pick up a camera
and start shooting something."
Lana and Lilly Wachowski, collectively known as
the Wachowskis, are two of the most unique and
entertaining directors working in Hollywood
today. They made their mark on the industry
in 1999 with the release of the sci-fi classic
"The Matrix," which they co-wrote and directed.
The Wachowskis followed a nontraditional
path to becoming Hollywood A-listers,
having started in the world of comic
books. Instead of going to film school,
they went to college for other subjects,
but they both dropped out before graduating.
The pair worked in construction for a bit, and
in 1993, they wrote for Marvel Comics' imprint,
Razorline's Barkerverse. They continued to work
in comics, initially conceiving "The Matrix" for
that medium before transitioning
the story to the silver screen.
Before that happened, though, they had
gone to Warner Bros. with the script to
an action-thriller called "Assassins." The
film got a page-one rewrite and failed to
turn much of a profit, making
the Wachowskis realize that if
they wanted their visions brought to life
properly, they needed to do it themselves.
They directed their first film, "Bound," for a few
million dollars, and it became a critical success.
After seeing what the pair could do behind the
camera, producer Joel Silver gave the green
light to the movie the Wachowskis were dying to
make. Their third film for Warner Bros. was "The
Matrix," and the sisters have continued to make
movies in their own trademark style ever since.
Ava DuVernay made her way to the film industry
much later than most of her peers. She was 32
when she picked up a camera for the first time,
and doing so was the result of a career change.
She started working in journalism when she
helped cover the O.J. Simpson trial, but she
soon became disillusioned with the industry.
From there, she worked in public relations and
made a move to filmmaking in her early thirties.
In an interview with Refinery29, DuVernay said —
"Can a director also have my hair, and my skin,
and be a girl… Yes, everyone can be it all."
DuVernay's debut film, "I Will
Follow," was a small indie that
garnered great reviews and opened the
door for her to score some big-budget
projects. On the subject of her
first film, DuVernay elaborated —
Terry Gilliam was the only
American member of Monty Python,
and he spent much of his time creating the
group's animated segments. He also performed
with the group and directed "Monty Python and
the Holy Grail," which became a massive hit.
When Gilliam started out, directing movies
wasn't on the horizon, as he started out as
a strip cartoonist and animator. He did this with
a BA in political science from Occidental College.
Through his work with Help! magazine, Gilliam
met John Cleese, and after moving to England,
he met Eric Idle, Michael Palin, and
Terry Jones. Regarding film school,
Gilliam has opposed the concept,
having spoken about it numerous times.
During an appearance on "Roundhouse" in 2007,
Gilliam expressed the opinion that if someone
only studies the technical aspect of filmmaking,
they'll be unprepared to get to work making
movies. In a Facebook post in 2011, Gilliam
doubled down on his opinion of film schools,
saying it was for fools. The director wrote —
Quentin Tarantino is arguably the most successful
independent filmmaker of all time, and his work
speaks for itself. His first directorial effort
was "Reservoir Dogs," which quickly established
the young director as a force to be reckoned with.
He solidified his name in Hollywood history with
his second film, "Pulp Fiction" — and from
there, he consistently made hit after hit.
Tarantino didn't attend film school: in fact,
he dropped out of the ninth grade. However,
he took acting classes at the James
Best Theater Company. He also worked
for five years at Video Archives
in Manhattan Beach, California,
where he further educated himself on
the artistry and history of cinema.
"I got hired because I was a film
expert. And then I had five years
to just do nothing but watch films
instead of get a job for a life."
Tarantino has discussed his lack of
formal training throughout his career:
during a Cinema Master Class at
Cannes, he told audience members —
Tarantino expanded on this during his
time at the film festival, elaborating —
Those films made Tarantino into the
violence-loving auteur that we know him as today.
Joel and Ethan Coen comprise the filmmaking duo
collectively known as the Coen brothers. Joel has
been credited as director since their first
film, "Blood Simple," hit theaters in 1984,
while Ethan was uncredited in that
role until 2004's "Ladykillers."
Regardless, both brothers write,
produce, and direct — together,
they've created "The Big Lebowski,"
"Fargo," and "No Country for Old
Men," but that's a fraction of
their outstanding body of work.
Joel indeed went to film school, having
attended the film program at NYU. Ethan,
too, was no slouch in the education department,
but he instead earned an undergraduate degree
in philosophy from Princeton. If you've seen his
movies, that might not come as much of a surprise.
Still, a philosophy degree isn't the same thing
as film school. At a press conference for "Hail,
Caesar!" in 2016, Ethan spoke
about his education, saying —
Julie Taymor has been ensconced in
the world of theater since 1980,
and it's a world she knows all too well. In 1997,
her adaptation of "The Lion King" became
the most-watched Broadway production of
her generation — and according to Playbill, it's
the highest-grossing Broadway show of all time.
Taymor didn't study film in college, as
it wasn't her primary interest — rather,
dance and film have driven her throughout her
professional career. Her films are reminiscent
of theatrical work, and it's easy to see how that
background drives her vision on the big screen.
Taymor began working in film in the early
1990s. Her feature debut, the highly successful
adaptation of William Shakespeare's "Titus
Andronicus" called "Titus," gained worldwide
recognition. It did decently upon release
and has gone on to become a cult classic.
Taymor followed up "Titus" in 2002
with "Frida," a biopic of the artist
Frida Kahlo. That movie earned
Taymor even more critical acclaim,
which she continued to enjoy with "Across the
Universe," "The Tempest," and "The Glorias."
Steven Spielberg is the highest-grossing
director of all time, and easily one of
the most influential directors of the last 50
years. Making movies was something Spielberg
wanted to do ever since he was a kid: he shot
a nine-minute film called "The Last Gunfight"
for a Boy Scouts merit badge, and continued
shooting movies with his father's 8mm camera.
Spielberg applied for the film programs at
UCLA and USC, but he was rejected because of
his grades. Spielberg wanted nothing
more than to be a filmmaker, though,
and he wasn't going to let rejections from
film schools keep him from pursuing his dream.
He attended classes at California
State University, Long Beach,
but dropped out when he scored a
deal to write and direct the short
film "Amblin'." This early effort earned him a
seven-year contract with Universal Television,
making him the youngest director at
a major studio in Hollywood history.
From there, he became the most successful
film director of all time — and he did it
without attending film school. That said,
Spielberg did return to college in 2002 to
finish what he started at California State
University, Long Beach. After 33 years away,
Spielberg finally took home a
BA in Film and Electronic Media.
"But you're better at this
than you were in school."
"Oh damn, damn straight!"
Stanley Kubrick is one of the
greatest filmmakers of all time,
and his work has influenced generations
of filmmakers. Interestingly,
Kubrick's interests weren't initially
as aligned with filmmaking as they were
with the technology and cameras used in the
process. His first career was in photography,
though he didn't attend university to pursue
that dream. Instead, he sold prints to Look
magazine shortly after graduating high school
and went on to become a staff photographer.
Kubrick always loved cinema, and after some time,
he left Look to make films on tiny budgets by
renting cameras and scraping together savings.
He studied the technical aspects of filmmaking
on his own, and after a great deal of work,
he was able to push his way into the industry,
becoming an internationally recognized artist.
Kubrick told Joseph Gelmis that working on every
aspect of his first two films helped teach him a
great deal. When asked if he would attend film
school if he were starting over, Kubrick said —